this is my last ever
time that I'll do this and then it's
blown my mind that you've done this for
me you're one of my best friends in the
whole world and you are mine
I love you oh let the tears flow girl
[Music]
Adele gets emotional with James Corden
during the final carpool karaoke my last
guest is gonna be
huge pop star
as James says goodbye to The Late Late
Show after eight years with the show
officially ending April 27th I can't
imagine what it's going to be like for
you when you get through that final show
I'm gonna be a mess
I'm just trying I just don't want to
become a meme it's the last week of The
Late Late Show so I'm going to wake
James up I'm driving the 21 minute clip
starts with Adele's surprising James at
his home
thank you
once at the talk show host hops in the
car with the singer
laughs
I can't believe we just pulled out of
your drive another crash the two
reminisce over carpool karaoke's iconic
moments it's a magical environment
including guests like Mariah Carey
and Stevie Wonder Who even called
James's wife Julia with this special
message
[Music]
I don't know even thinking about it I
could cry my eyes out speaking of James
and Julia Adele reveals they've been two
of her greatest confidants for years
absolutely especially after she moved to
Los Angeles following her split from
Simon kaneki the father of her son
Angelo so you were like always an adult
to me like you and Judy are very much
and you would always give me this advice
so that I remember I said to you on the
way home I thought what's wrong I was
like you just sitting down and you had
it all out to me James even inspiring
one of her most recent hits after an
intimate six hour conversation they
shared I was flawed by
how
you'd managed to take everything that I
was feeling about myself and
life and just put it in a verse a verse
that leaves James in tears it will make
me cry I love you lyrics as well
[Music]
how come we both become a version of a
person we don't even like yep that's
Adele's I drink wine
[Music]
it's all feels overwhelming right now
and the emotions keep flowing as it hits
Adele that James is also saying goodbye
to Los Angeles
I love you I knew we have had the best
times here and oh my God we really have
our
friendship and our family's friendship
is absolutely not
it has nothing to do with distance Adele
first appeared on carpool karaoke back
in 2016 the segment becoming one of the
most popular late night clips on YouTube
of all time yeah no it's been a complete
world with it's like so much fun so it
was only right to end the iconic series
with the band I miss it every day
every single day I'll miss it and I'll
always think
oh that was the thing that I did
and how great
[Music]